hey guys Ryan writes is yep
try not to say rider right over here
anymore correct rare rare rare what's
your name
Brandi price there you go so today we're
gonna check out this video that people
have been asking us to check out tight
pants body rolls I don't know yeah
whatever let's watch us okay I was
walking through the forest of moccasin
bread when I saw a troll while wearing
tight ass I want to own them but can you
examples thing about the shoes all sweet
tender like a tiny baby kitty I need to
get some baby no that's a lady
this is how we yeah I beg that point you
baked me some I live like that where I
come from grab a partner flavor line
cutting stitch a big shiny work leather
last take it smoking fans please this
you're free because my body can't handle
cell power over my life
tickles my tightrope cited them stretch
stretch to your vessel to release watch
my feet pound goals in watch my hips
crush laser Bank watch out for my body
rolls watch out for my body rolls my
kicks
I think this is how we do
my body for my body rolls like this this
is how we do it twice the last ditch all
the fine see he plays on to my leg hair
sliver to treat I know I needed them
more than any love that my never I was
already wearing time I just did not
today down Wow body roll body high kick
high kick this is how we do it what you
said
try not to get turned off with dams for
Tiger lady bomb and everything she had
Justin every single fan from every
meeting read work that dance floor they
may don't you pay your jazz one day have
a black and sexy or the tightest of my
body rolls watch out for my body rolls
high kicks high kicks this is how we do
it
watch out for my body rolls for my body
rolls high kicks
hi kids this is how we do it that's
catchy
that's really catchy I love that woman
I love how committed she was she was so
committed to that bit and that guy he
had like the highest kiss yeah I love
the way it was shot it had like that
music video of the 90s kind of vibe or
it was it was pretty [ __ ] funny
I love seeing female comedians really
commit to going all out like that she's
like what for my body rolls she would be
good at games like Dance Central you
know or you have to like do dance moves
are like if she's in a class I think
she'd be good like I know it was a joke
because she's supposed to be like a
little heavyset and stuff but still it
was funny it's pretty funny and at the
same time I was like she can move for
the most part yeah for the most part she
can move those hips and stuff so that
was really cool this year really commit
to that bit I love the random zaniness
of it all that was very [ __ ] funny
and their costumes were hilarious
costumes were funny just the way we shot
was really smart on the green screen
yeah the green Oh bad green screen
effects and the little guys and stuff
where it's just like what's the point
cake on that with some point but then
she did it yeah this is one of those
things really like
the point of this what it was it was so
worth it what was the point of that
there wasn't there wasn't a point to
make you laugh that is the point
mm-hmm I think that was the point it
worked it worked we were laughing I will
have a mission accomplished
thanks for telling us to watch that
video if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the Rio rejects and you
can follow Brandi on her channel check
it out it's a good channel covers a lot
independent stuff you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram or Twitter where we
do a lot of fun posting and stuff you're
gonna have a good time
what are you
check this out Brandi check this out I
want you to act scared I'm a giant
monster
ah